Five years ago, I experienced a bit of what it must have been like to be Alice in Wonderland.
Penn State asked me, a communications teacher,...
...to teach a communications class for engineering students.
And I was scared,...
...really scared,...
...scared of these students with their big brains and their big books and their big, unfamiliar words.
But as these conversations unfolded,...
...I experienced what Alice must have when she went down that rabbit hole...
...and saw that door to a whole new world.
That's just how I felt as I had those conversations with the students.
I was amazed at the ideas that they had,...
...and I wanted others to experience this wonderland as well,...
...and I believe the key to opening that door is great communication.
We desperately need great communication from our scientists and engineers...
...in order to change the world.
Our scientists and engineers are the ones that are tackling our grandest challenges,...
...from energy to environment to health care, among others,...
...and if we don't know about it and understand it, then the work isn't done,...
...and I believe it's our responsibility as non-scientists to have these interactions.
But these great conversations can't occur if our scientists and engineers...
...don't invite us in to see their wonderland.
So scientists and engineers, please, talk nerdy to us.
I want to share a few keys on how you can do that...
...to make sure that we can see that your science is sexy...
...and that your engineering is engaging.
First question to answer for us: So what?
Tell us why your science is relevant to us.
Don't just tell me that you study trabeculae, but tell me that you study trabeculae,...
...which is the mesh-like structure of our bones...
...because it's important to understanding and treating osteoporosis.
And when you're describing your science, beware of jargon.
Jargon is a barrier to our understanding of your ideas.
Sure, you can say "spatial and temporal," but why not just say "space and time,"...
...which is so much more accessible to us?
And making your ideas accessible is not the same as dumbing it down.
Instead, as Einstein said, make everything as simple as possible, but no simpler.
You can clearly communicate your science without compromising the ideas.
A few things to consider are having examples, stories and analogies.
Those are ways to engage and excite us about your content.
And when presenting your work, drop the bullet points.
Have you ever wondered why they're called bullet points?
What do bullets do?
Bullets kill, and they will kill your presentation.